ja vieles hat sich verändert schauen wir
noch mal auf China das Land hatte eine
Friedensinitiative angekündigt die mit
Spannung erwartet wurde und heute Nacht
deutscher Zeit hat Peking dann ein zwölf
punkte-papier vorgelegt darüber kann ich
jetzt mit Elisabeth Schmidt sprechen ja
Frau Schmidt worum geht es in diesem 12
Punkte Papier
es ist genau ein Papier ein
Positionspapier und eben keinen
Friedensplan Hauptpunkt ist dass China
die beiden Kriegsparteien zurück an den
Verhandlungstisch bittet sie rufen zu
einem Waffenstillstand auf zu besprechen
und Verhandlungen diese Waffenruhe aus
chinesischer Sicht kommt aber mit einer
Bedingung es werden nämlich alle
westlichen Sanktionen gegen Russland zum
sofortigen Stopp aufgerufen da gibt es
noch ein paar allgemeine Formulierungen
da geht es auch um eine Warnung an
Russland die kriegt nicht weiter zu
eskalieren soll auf Atomwaffen
verzichtet werden auf chemische und
biologische Waffen aber wer dieses 12
Punkte Papier genau liest den fallen vor
allem die vielen Spitzen gegen die NATO
und die USA auf die beiden werden nicht
direkt erwähnt aber es fallen so
Formulierungen wie die Kriegsparteien
sollen kein weiteres Öl ins Feuer gießen
diesen Satz haben wir in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten sehr oft hier in
China gehört und immer war gemeint die
USA die mit ihren Waffenlieferungen aus
chinesischer Sicht sogar Schuld an
diesem Krie Ukraine sein es waren dann
noch weitere man muss schon sagen
Propaganda Floskeln etwa ja man soll die
alte alte kriegsmentalität App bin ich
ablegen außerdem sollte man die
Souveränität und den legitimen
Sicherheitsanspruch von Staaten
respektieren das ist eins zu eins die
Propaganda Russlands die China seit
Wochen und Monaten hier wiederholt also
Fazit China ist nicht wirklich ein
glaubhafter Vermittler in diesem
Konflikt oder was sagen sie
ja um einen neutraler Vermittler zu sein
müsste man ja mit beiden Kriegsparteien
in gleicher Weise kommunizieren bislang
war es so in diesem ein Jahr ein
kokainekrieg hat Putin und Präsident
mehrmals miteinander telefoniert sie
haben sich auch physisch getroffen mit
der Ukraine hatte sie keinen Kontakt
soweit wir zumindest wissen Präsident
selenski hat mehrmals fast schon
flehendlich um ein Gespräch mit China
gebeten einmal in einem Zeitungsartikel
und jetzt heute am Jahrestag des Krieges
nochmals um ein Gespräch gebitten
bislang gab es aus chinesischer Sicht
überhaupt keine Antwort also China
versucht sich gerne als Vermittler zu
inszenieren aber man muss sagen eine
neutrale Position sieht wirklich anders
aus also worauf zieht dieses
Positionspapier dann vielleicht ab oder
was ist der Plan dahinter sie haben die
Gegensätze ja schon erwähnt also zum
einen wird die Souveränität und
territoriale Integrität aller Länder
erwähnt als Gegensatz dazu aber auch
legitime sicherheits-
wohin will man mit diesem
Positionspapier aus chinesischer Sicht
dann
das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen vage
also China nutzt gerade die große
Weltbühne um sich zu inszenieren auf der
anderen Seite hat China überhaupt kein
Interesse daran dass Russland geschwächt
aus diesen Krieg hervorgeht dazu sind
auch diese wirtschaftlichen
Verflechtungen zwischen China und
Russland viel zu groß allein im letzten
Jahr ist der Westen auf russisches Öl
verzichtet hat stand China zur Stelle
und hat das Öl aufgekauft auch im Jahr
davor gab es viele viele Handlungen ähm
Handel wurde getrieben und es wurde
sogar so viel angetrieben wie noch nie
zuvor ein neues Hoch wurde erreicht also
da sind die Abhängigkeiten gigantisch
auf der anderen Seite hat natürlich auch
Chinas Image in der Welt unfassbar
gelitten durch die strenge Kurve Politik
und jetzt versucht mein Leben zu steuern
wir erinnern uns an die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vorher auch schon
das Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos da hat
sich China auf quasi Schaum Offensive
beim Westen befunden weil man eben auch
immer noch von westlicher Technologie
abhängig ist also China ist da so ein
bisschen in der Rolle dazwischen und
dieses Positionspapier muss man sagen da
sieht sich China vor allem selbst als
der nicht nächste China denkt vor allem
an China und zwar weil es den globalen
Süden im Blick hat wir haben es vorhin
im Beitrag schon gehört China dass es
die Langzeitstrategie da das Land
verfolgt hat vor allem die Länder in
Afrika in Lateinamerika im Blick Länder
die gerade durch diesen Krieg besonders
gelitten hatten wir haben es gesehen
Nahrungsmittelpreise sind angestiegen
aber auch die Energiepreise und das
erschwert die Armutsbekämpfung in diesen
Ländern China voll versucht dort Fuß zu
fassen Loyalitäten zu gewinnen und will
sich jetzt eben als die Weise ja
verantwortungsbewusste Welt macht
generieren im Gegensatz zu den USA die
Kriegstreiber dargestellt wird also
China umwirbt den globalen Süden zum
Abschluss vielleicht noch einmal einen
ein Stimmungsbild wie wird denn dieser
Jahrestag des Kriegsbeginn in den
chinesischen Medien kommentiert
das ist ganz interessant die Ukraine
wird hier vor allem als Opfer
dargestellt man wird man liest Beiträge
Reportagen zum Beispiel auch Buja wir
erinnern uns an die furchtbaren Bilder
dieses Massakers allerdings wird in den
chinesischen Medien kein Wort darüber
verloren also es geht eher darum die
armen Ukraine da sind viele gestorben
und jetzt können sie in ihre zerbombenen
Häuser nicht zurückkehren sie will auch
sehr oft betont wie wirtschaftlich am
Boden dieses Land ist und als Adresse
wird ähnlich wie in der russischen
Propaganda immer die NATO gesehen das
ist eben dieses narrativ Russland haben
sich bedroht gefühlt durch die NATO Ost
Erweiterung und jetzt sich quasi legitim
gewehrt ein anderer Artikel ist mir ins
Auge gestochen da stand noch mal drin
das ist ja überhaupt kein Zweifel gäbe
dass sich Russland zum Beispiel aus dem
Osten der Ukraine zurückziehen müsste
denn da gäbe es ja legitime Referenten
und der Don Bass zum Beispiel würde
längst zu Russland gehören also man
sieht auf welcher klaren Seite hier
zumindest die chinesische
Staatspropaganda steht ja vielen Dank
für diese Hintergründe Elisabeth Schmidt
live aus Peking danke